aquí tenemos 6 distintas expresiones y
para empezar quiero que le pongas pausa
al vídeo e intentes evaluarlas por tu
cuenta
supongo que ya lo intentaste ahora vamos
a evaluarlas cuando vemos algo así
tenemos que recordar el orden de las
operaciones aquí tenemos dos por tres
elevado al cuadrado tenemos que recordar
que el orden es primero paréntesis vamos
a ponerlo aquí paréntesis primero
resolvemos todos los paréntesis y luego
exponentes
exponentes luego tenemos multiplicación
y división de ge poner lo mejor de la
siguiente manera multiplicación y
división y finalmente tenemos suma y
resta así es que en esta expresión que
tenemos aquí no tenemos paréntesis por
lo cual hacemos primero el exponente
calculamos entonces 3 al cuadrado 3 por
3 es 9 ahora hacemos el producto 2 por 9
es igual a 18 así es que esta expresión
es igual a 18 hagamos la siguiente es
interesante pues se parece a la que
acabamos de hacer sin embargo aquí
tenemos paréntesis y debido a este
paréntesis tenemos que hacer primero la
multiplicación y después elevar al
cuadrado hacemos la multiplicación y nos
da dos por tres es igual a 6 y esto
elevado al cuadrado 6 elevado al
cuadrado es 6 por 6 lo cual es igual a
36 hagamos ahora esta que tenemos aquí
en este caso queremos hacer la
multiplicación y la división primero
aquí tenemos una división 81 sobre 9 es
81 entre 9 la cual vamos el primero 80
entre 9 es igual a 9 y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por 5 en 3 sería 15 por 9
5 por 9 es 45 es la multiplicación que
hay que hacer antes de la suma 5 por 9
esto es igual a 45 y a eso le sumamos 1
para obtener uno más 45 46 hagamos ahora
esta que tenemos aquí por supuesto hay
que hacer primero el exponente 1 al
cuadrado esto es 11 al cuadrado es 1
vamos a ponerlo con otro color de que
ponerlo con otro color 1 al cuadrado es
1 y ahora que vamos a el primero 2 x 4
vamos a hacer la suma con 1 bueno la
multiplicación tiene precedencia sobre
la suma entonces hacemos 2 por 4 que es
igual a 8 esto va a ser 2 por 4 que es
igual a 8 ya eso le vamos a sumar 1 que
obtuvimos aquí y por supuesto 8 más uno
es igual a 9
ahora tenemos una expresión muy similar
pero aquí tenemos paréntesis por lo cual
tenemos que hacer primero lo que está
entre paréntesis
antes de elevar al exponente dentro del
paréntesis tenemos multiplicación y suma
tenemos que recordar que hay que hacer
primero la multiplicación así es que
hacemos primero dos por cuatro que es
igual a ocho más uno y eso lo elevamos
al cuadrado ocho más uno es igual a
nueve así es que esto es nueve elevado
al cuadrado nueve elevado al cuadrado es
nueve por nueve lo cual es igual a 81
hagamos el último el cual es muy similar
al que hicimos aquí nada más que aquí
tenemos paréntesis por lo cual tenemos
que hacer la suma primero sin paréntesis
hicimos la división y la multiplicación
primero pero aquí tenemos que hacer
primero 15 que 6 y aquí tenemos 81 entre
9 que es 9 así es que esto resulta en 6
por 9 que es igual a 54